on va continuer de parler de la
situation au liban avec fouad zmokhol
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise
libanais dans le monde
bonjour fois de ce mot cole merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a dit un les libanais attendent des
réponses à face aux incertitudes
économiques et sécuritaires est ce que
la nomination d'un premier ministre
pourrait apaiser les tensions au liban
tout d'abord bonjour bonjour du liban
écoutez votre votre question est très
pertinente aujourd'hui est-ce que la
nomination de rémy nice je vais aller
plus loin à ce qu'aujourd'hui un nouveau
ministère à la tête de ceux de ce
diplomate quel que soit le ministère est
ce que le problème c'est la
malheureusement le problème n'est pas là
ni dans la nomination du vinyle début du
premier ministre ni des ministres ni
même dans l'action le gros problème
aujourd'hui c'est avoir un vrai plan de
sauvetage pour le liban une application
et un suivi et c'est là le gros problème
qu'on a eue au liban sur les dernières
30 années on a toujours eu un premier
ministre même avec des difficultés on
sait que même si ce premier ministre est
nommé dernièrement il aura du beau
beaucoup de travail pour pouvoir nommer
un ministère parce qu'on sait vous
l'avait bien dit dans votre reportage
sur la divine diversité secteurs
politiques partisanes et autres et une
fois que ce gouvernement sera mis en
place on sait que ce sera très difficile
d'avoir un vrai plan de secours mais
surtout une application claire et un
suivi aujourd'hui on s'attend beaucoup
de la visite du président macron
j'aimerais dire que la première visite
qu'il a effectuée juste après
l'explosion a redonné une lueur d'espoir
à une population complètement désemparés
ne doit vraiment insisté qu on a une
population libanaise qui a tout perdu et
perdu son pouvoir d'achat sa qualité de
vie son travail et dernièrement sa
maison quand une explosion qui rentrent
et au fin fond de sa maison donc
aujourd'hui on s'attend bien sûr à ce
support psychologique on voit en tout
cas en photo le président macron a
réussi ce qu'aucun politicien libanais
n'aurait osé faire descendre dans les
rues ils auraient été accueillis par des
pierres et les injures le président
macron a été accueilli comme un héros
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui en tant
que population libanaise en tant que
chef d'entreprise on s'attend à plus on
s'attend à plus de la france parce
on a vraiment besoin pas d'un plan mais
on a besoin de pression et quand je dis
dépression c'est des pressions
politiques internationales
aujourd'hui si on veut reconstruire ce
vrai liban qui ce soit à l'état laïc ou
autre on a besoin de pressions
internationales et là je vais être très
spécifiques
la première phase on sait parfaitement
que je me permets de vous de vous couper
parce que vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'un plan de secours ce sont des mots
assez forts 1
est-ce que déjà la nomination d'un
premier ministre nouveau premier
ministre pourrait être la première étape
d'un plan de secours et puis en termes
de premier ministre on parle de mustapha
a dit c'est un ancien ambassadeur du
liban en allemagne déjà est ce que vous
le connaissez et est-ce que
potentiellement cet homme pourrait être
un bon choix pour le pour le poste de
premier ministre libanais écoutez oui je
connais bien
monsieur ladib il faut rappeler qu'il
veut c'est la dip était directeur du
cabinet du premier ministre nagib mikati
donc qui vient aussi bon peut-être
technocrates mais de l'arène politique
il n'ya rien à dire de mauvais en tout
cas ce monsieur a été ambassadeur du
liban en allemagne mais je vous redis
cher monsieur le gros problème ce n'est
pas les personnes le gros problème c'est
vraiment une certaine acceptation et
l'implémentation de plans on a eu des
plans sur l'électricité on a eu des
plans économique on a eu des plans pour
faire plaisir aux fonds monétaires
on n'a jamais eu une application on n'a
jamais eu vraiment un pouvoir politique
qui a soutenu donc ce soit ce monsieur
ou quelqu'un d'autre s'il vient
exactement comme a été nominé le dernier
premier ministre ça sera le le le même
résultat je dis malheureusement s'il n'y
a pas vraiment une volonté politique de
changement mais je dis bien aussi une
volonté internationale
aujourd'hui aucun premier ministre aucun
ministre ou seul peut réformer le
système où nous sommes
j'étais en train de dire qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'un support
international
je dis bien qu'ils aient pu mettre des
sanctions parce que si on sanctionne pas
un pouvoir politique il ya des l'habite
et le fonds des libanais dit d'aller
vite et les entreprises est directement
responsable de cette crise économique
sociale et même cette explosion ça sera
toujours lettre morte on sera simplement
pas en train de gagner du temps on sait
qu on ira sur des élections françaises
et les six des élections américaines et
autres donc on pourra perdre et
l'importance internationale mais au
liban on sera en train de retourner je
dis bien vous
auriez vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
visite des manuels macro quelques jours
après les explosions les terribles
explosions qui ont eu lieu à beyrouth le
4 août dernier
qu'est ce que le liban attend de la
france et qu'est ce que la france peut
faire aujourd'hui pour le liban regardez
la première visite des présidents macron
était vraiment une visite de support
psychologique comme je disais à une
population complètement désemparé il y
avait besoin de toute lueur d'espoir aux
petites branches alors pour s'accrocher
pari gagné parce que je disais que le
président macron a été accueillie
vraiment comme un héros contrairement à
toutes autres politiciens libanais qui
auraient été accueillis par l'été à les
injures bon
pari gagné mais aujourd'hui on s'attend
par les actions beaucoup plus concrète
je dis bien par la france et par la
communauté internationale le premier la
première demande je le disais les
dessins c'est des sanctions contre tout
ce qu'on appelle les pets politically
exposed personnes donc toutes les
personnes et leurs familles qui ont
travaillé dans l'arène politique
et quand je dis sanction ce n'est pas
simplement pour les sanctionner parce
que si on ne sanctionne pas ces
personnes
c'est exactement les mêmes qui ont les
pompes ils vont revenir au liban pour
investir dans tout projet de
privatisation de beauté ou autre ce sont
les mêmes ils vont financer des
élections même si on va sur les
élections anticipées
on sait qu'une grande partie des
élections est financée par des fonds
locaux et ces fonds viendront de ces
personnes le troisième point on a besoin
du président de maquereaux et de la
france d'un support international c'est
impossible de s'en sortir tout seul si
on n'a pas un support des nations unies
d'abord sur une loi électorale et une
révision une surveillance électorale
toute élection qui se passera au liban
va ramener 80 à 90 personnes des mêmes
partis
donc aujourd'hui on a besoin du support
des nations unies et on a besoin d'un
support des nations unies pour
surveiller quand même nos frontières on
sait qu'on a besoin qu'on a un gros
problème sur les frontières se soient
maritimes et terrestres ou aériennes
aujourd'hui tout seul en tant que
libanais on ne pourra pas le faire et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la france et la
communauté internationale doit être à
nos côtés
notre problème est très grand économique
social sécuritaire et politique
aujourd'hui on a la volonté en tant que
chef d'entreprise de cons reconstruire
ce qui a été vraiment détruites
non peut pas le construire sur les mêmes
bases on peut pas le contenir sur les
mêmes personnes et ces mêmes personnes
ne seront mises en dehors de leur zone
de confort que si vraiment on applique
des sanctions internationales à tous les
niveaux as
- là je dis bien à ces sanctions ils
seront prêts à négocier
ils seront prêts à venir sur une table
de négociations sinon malheureusement ce
sera impossible donc j'espère vraiment
que cette visite du président macron
pourra pousser cette communauté
internationale sur ces grands points que
je viens de dire merci beaucoup fouad
zmokhol d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france je rappelle que vous êtes
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise elle
libanais dans le monde merci beaucoup